thanks so much it's great to be here to
talk about the human microbiome today
since we have people from a variety of
backgrounds i'm going to start with some
introductory information i also ask that
you feel free to interrupt or ask a
question during the talk if um i'm
losing you because this is a complicated
stuff at least from the biological
perspective
so we're going to be speaking about the
collection of thousands of different
types of microbes bacteria archaea fungi
uh our
viruses that collectively are called the
human microbiome they live in and on our
bodies
and
about half of the cells in your body
come from bacteria and they're of all
different types and have different
genomes
hence um their genes outnumber the genes
encoded in your human genome by about a
hundred to one
and these are not passive bystanders we
know about pathogens we know
that we're aware of our microbiome when
we're sick but it's also an integral
part of our normal biology and health
the microbial cells are integrated with
the human cells in our organs our
secreting molecules our signaling are
communicating with our cells and with
our genetic material
and um
really make us who we are and yet uh not
too long ago uh
everyone
just essentially including myself were
very focused on the human genome and
understanding how it dictated our health
how it encoded disease
but it
it would be negligent to not consider
these other genomes in our bodies
because uh a lot of the answers to these
questions i i would posit lie in these
other genomes that we've ignored up till
now so why
were they ignored up till now well we
didn't have a good way to measure them
and that's because the vast majority of
these organisms cannot be isolated from
the human body and studied in the
laboratory
by classical microbiological techniques
however
genomic sequencing gives us a way to
footprint or measure what's there by
looking at its biomolecules and reading
out its sequences and if we can decode
that information we might understand
who's there and what they're doing
this isn't totally new to do this for
over three decades
we've had an approach to go in and
target a single gene that's present in
every microbial cell
and
in particular the 16s ribosomal rna is a
good marker in bacteria and archaea
and it's a gene we can sequence a little
piece of it target and sequence it and
those pieces are different between
different species of microbes and so by
looking at the sequences that we obtain
that i'm indicating here
by these blue lines and looking at
sequence variations in them compared to
a reference database we can make an
inference about what organisms are
present
but there are some biases and certainly
some limitations to this approach
one of which is it doesn't tell us
anything about the rest of the genome of
these organisms and its resolution is
good to about the genus and maybe the
species but as i'm going to argue today
a lot of the important variation in the
human microbiome is at a subspecies
level
we
have a more recent technique that's just
come on the scenes in the last decade to
sequence all of the dna in a sample
without this pcr step called shotgun
metagenomic sequencing
and i'm showing here a simple microbiome
with just two genomes in it a pink
organism and a green organism and the
result of the experiment is again little
sequencing reads that i'm denoting in
blue here and they're a random sample
from across the genomes of the different
organisms here and i'm showing less of
them on the
aligned here to the yellow genome
because perhaps this is less abundant so
if i sequence a certain amount i see
more sequences from the pink genome
what's
challenging about analyzing this data
is that all we get are the blue
sequences we don't know which genome
they came from and there aren't two
there could be thousands in the sample
and we don't know the relative amounts
of each one and so we just have this
pool of sequencing reads and we need to
deconvolute it that's the problem that
we work on
so
the data
is big
and i'm not going to talk too much about
algorithms today i'm going to talk more
about statistics
but
there are a lot of major algorithmic
challenges in this field that i'd love
to discuss with folks we have a great
need for people thinking about how to
handle big data in the field essentially
we're using the tools from human
genetics and genomics
and the data sets are orders of
magnitude bigger and more complicated
because they're these complex mixtures
so we're hobbling along
but i spend a lot of time actually
thinking about hardware and the network
and things like this that we had solved
pretty well in human genomics but they
just break completely with these data
sets
this is
example of the top of a file that we
might look at where the sequences are
say a hundred letters long i'm not
showing all 100 letters there obviously
and one of these files which would be
the sequences obtained say from your
saliva after you spat in a test tube for
me
would have about 50 million for example
of these 100
base baseball long sequences these
sequences of ac's t's and g's so that's
the data
and i don't know which one comes from
which organism or from which gene in
those organisms
and the questions
the basic descriptive statistics i would
like is i'd like to know which organisms
are present and how much of each one
and i'd also like to know what genes are
there what and how much of each one so
are the not just what kind of microbes
do i have but are do they have enzymes
to do a particular reaction are they
secreting a protein that's going to
dampen my immune response or
elevate it
and so these are the basic
quantities that we've been trying to
estimate from this data
any questions up till there because
everything follows from this
okay
awesome hopefully you're on board so
here's what's happened in this field we
had no data um and uh until about 2010
and then this experiment started
happening
and not surprisingly people have been
doing a lot of experiments and so we now
in public databases and this is just the
uh sra there's some data in europe
that's not in the sra and vice versa but
this is one of the major databases has
about 120 terabytes of this data
and it's growing all the time
and
the
my lab spends a lot of time mining this
publicly available data
and
quite a few studies have been done in
different countries
and
with individuals who are healthy as well
as with various diseases
most of these have been in europe and
north america there's been a big cohort
study in china and more recently a
couple of studies and individuals in
non-industrialized living
non-industrialized lifestyles either
hunter-gatherers or agriculturalists
in africa and peru and there's more of
this kind of data as well as these guys
non-human primates coming down the pipe
so we will have comparative data um but
a lot of it's been case contr as in
human genetics a lot of the field got
launched with sort of case control
studies of diseases in uh north america
and europe
so
um i'm going to show you three troubling
results and that'll be the motivation
for what we're going to talk about today
here's the first one
we
got a hold of a bunch of these day
publicly available data sets and we did
a meta-analysis where we asked whether
this
result that ruthlay published
showing that obese individuals had more
of this particular phylum of bacteria
called firmicutes
then lean individuals in the same cohort
of college students
we wanted to see how that held out
across other publicly available data
and
disturbingly there was no consistent
association with obesity so the result
didn't replicate
including maybe in some of the studies
that trend in the opposite direction
but what i actually want to focus on
today
is
what i found more shocking which was
that this biomarker the amount of this
particular bacteria differed from about
80 on average in this study to about 20
on average of the sequencing library in
this other study
so is that real biology
do
do people differ that much in the amount
of this particular bacterium
consistently between different studies
so this is the human microbiome project
those are adults living in st louis
and in san antonio
uh these were college students
is that really was that real biology is
that an experimental artifact is it
something about how the data was uh
processed before i got to it and
analyzed it together
what's going on
that's pretty striking that this heavily
touted biomarker would be that different
across studies why okay so that's the
first thing
the second thing
is from the human microbiome project in
which we were involved where
about 300 adults
healthy adults have their microbiome
sequenced and here's this same taxonomic
variability so some people this yellow
i believe either yellow or the green is
i think the green is the fermicutes so
these guys have almost 80 percent and
these people here have 20 so again we
see huge variability so maybe that's
real now this is within one study so
maybe that's real biology maybe not
and
um
strikingly though despite having totally
different phyla i mean these are very
very evolutionarily distant types of
bacteria dominating the yellows versus
the greens in these two microbiomes so
each
column here is a person and the colors
represent these are stacked bar charts
and each column is a person and each
color is a type of phylum of bacteria so
despite this huge difference
when we looked at biological pathways
they were totally stable
so does that mean
that it doesn't matter what you have we
just all they're all doing the same
thing anyway they're all doing the exact
same functions
and that was sort of the hand-wavy
argument that was made in the paper and
i didn't buy it that didn't make sense
to me
yeah so instead of meta genomes if you
just look in genomes and so that that
reveals part of the problem so
jumping ahead a little bit part of the
problem is these are very coarse
descriptions and things like central
carbon metabolism every organism has
them and so those even in genomes are
constant and so that's part of the
problem this is sort of looks more
stable than it really is because of the
resolution at which things were measured
and that's also becomes apparent when
you do the experiment that you described
but it doesn't explain everything so
that's part of it
so
the question was is there really
functional stability or not or is this
some artifact of the experiment or of
how we analyze the data then i've just
revealed that it was partly an artifact
of how we analyze the data but there are
some other things going on too
despite this stability we did ask if
there were any microbial genes that
associated with diseases so we looked in
these case control studies here's an
example of one where there were
individuals with crohn's disease and
healthy individuals here there's a
column for each
person in the study these are microbial
genes and the color is how much there is
and
if we test statistically for
differentially abundant genes ones that
are higher and or lower in disease than
expected
we get some housekeeping genes the
ribosome trna charging central carbon
metabolism these are things that should
not be varying
so despite the stability i showed on the
previous slide when you look for the
most variable things with
you know the sort of standard tools in
the field there they're actually things
that we know shouldn't be varying okay
so this is pointing that there's
actually a problem um and and luckily
actually the solution is sitting here
too and that's what i'm going to tell
you about in a minute
so
we've identified a bunch of the reasons
why we might get these confusing results
from data
a bunch of them have to do with the
experiment
these things induce bias essentially and
cause data to not be comparable across
studies or even within study if the data
were handled differently or generated
differently
there's actually a bunch of bias induced
by how you quality control the data when
we quality control to remove duplicate
reads or bad quality data
we think we're doing a good thing but
sometimes we actually induce bias there
and then
how we actually estimate how much there
is of a taxon or of a gene family
is really important so three different
sources of bias and
all of some of these have been
documented in the literature already
some um were known from rna sequencing
for example the gc bias of reads you
know that the probability of sequencing
a read isn't uniform it depends on the
gc content so some of these were known
some of these are things we helped to
unearth
but the question is are they important
so a bias can exist but if it doesn't
have an effect that's on the scale of
the biological variation in the data i
mean it's good to know about but it
wouldn't explain a twenty percent versus
eighty percent firm acutes in a data set
so are they really are these biases on
that scale or not and if they are can
they be corrected
so
um the experimental biases are actually
relatively small they're on the order of
the bias you would see just from
resampling the same person twice
um biological signal tends to swamp
these things so even though there is a
dna extraction bias that preferentially
with one of the kits preferentially
amplifies the permacutes relative to
other phyla it doesn't explain a 20
versus 80 percent difference
um so the argument we have there is that
you should just keep track of these
things and you can model them in the
downstream statistics and correct for
them
the quality control and also induces
some small biases
and in fact since it's very
computationally intensive we're
advocating maybe you skip this actually
i mean it doesn't necessarily do much
harm but it doesn't do much good either
and it takes up a lot of
juice on the computer so this is sort of
also good to know that it's not a
mandatory step interestingly
but what i'm going to focus on is the
quantification
so
before doing that
i want to mention this may sound like a
really bad news talk i'm saying all
these things that are wrong in the field
and in fact we have published results
sort of debunking some of the major
papers in the field but i don't only
have bad news today so in
getting really down in the trenches and
understanding what's going on with this
data and identifying these error sources
we've also found some opportunities so i
hope that the talk also has a positive
message
so there's a lot of work to identify
error we
create new tools computational tools for
this data which we implement in open
source software we correct our
inferences and and we feel like we're
getting closer to the truth of what's
going on with this data but in making
these tools we've also been able to ask
questions of the data that weren't
possible to ask previously so
um i have a few uh examples of that
which i think are sort of the silver
lining of this line of research that i
actually never intended to spend six or
seven years working on but we absolutely
had to solve these quantification
problems before we could do the fun
stuff
with this data
okay
a little bit more uh so i'm going to
talk about quantification and estimating
how much there is of a particular
microbe or a particular microbial gene
and why that's really hard with this
data
to start that conversation i want to
explain a little more clearly how we go
from the data that i showed you these
100 base pair sequences that are a
mixture of random pieces of different
genomes
to a
summary statistic
so
there are a number of different
approaches
and they generally do some sort of a
homology search
of your metagenome so these are the
sequences compare them either to a
database with lots of sequences
essentially everything that's ever been
sequenced before or
to a database of models of what gene
families look like the models allow you
to detect more distant homology these
are things for example profile hidden
markov models that describe
how a protein family evolves and
therefore allow you to detect sequences
that look like they come from the family
even if they aren't close enough to any
given example from that family you've
ever seen before this is very important
because the vast majority of the
microbes in one of these samples even in
a person in north america or europe
have
very little homology to anything that
we've ever sequenced there's a ton of
dark matter out there still so these
models can be very helpful
but
you can also do just an individual
sequence comparison and
this actually for short reads
performs better in some situations than
this so we had a paper talking about
when to do which of the different types
of search i'm not going to focus on that
today
the output is the number of sequencing
reads the number of these pieces of dna
that match a given gene or a given
microbe so a count
so that's the basic data
and it could be
one or two or it could be a very big
number yeah
we do a translated search because of
distant homology being really important
the the dna won't match at all a lot of
the times but if you uh translate the
read
you don't know what frame to translate
in and so they're metagenomic gene
finders that essentially
consider all six frames and make the
most likely orf out of your sequence
yeah
you can do a dna search it's not very
powerful
so you get a count and the question is
is that count comparable across studies
and and is um
failure for it to be comparable is that
going to explain some of the confounding
looking results that i showed at the
beginning so how do you compare it even
across two genes in the same sample and
that or a microbes and that's an issue
as anyone who's worked on rna-seq knows
you need to take the counts of reads
that map to a gene and you need to
normalize by the length of the gene
right
for example like a rpkm measurement
and
because it is longer you expect more
reads just by chance
and some of these genomes are much
bigger or smaller than others so that's
a real factor here and the problem is we
don't know their lengths those are
unknown here whereas
in transcriptomics on say the human or
mouse genome we pretty much at least
much much have a much better idea of the
lengths so you want to divide by the
length but you're not sure what what
that is and more importantly are these
counts comparable across samples
so
here's the standard approach
and then i'm going to explain what the
problems are with it the standard
approach is to take that count and if
you want to compare two microbes or two
genes you would divide by the length if
you knew it
and maybe you can estimate it from data
that you have seen before so you take a
stab at estimating it
to compare across samples you need to
think about how much you sequenced one
could be sequenced more than another we
know that also from human genomics that
you would normalize by your library size
by the if you sequence twice as much of
course you expect twice as many reads to
hit the gene
so you want to get a proportion and this
is called relative abundance in the
metagenomics literature that's the
typical thing to do
the problem here that happens a little
bit in
human genomics but not so much is that
the majority of the sequences will not
match anything in the database so we
have this huge pile of unmapped reeds
and they are a mixture of actual
microbial genes
that should have mapped but our database
is just insufficient
because most of the things there have
never been seen before or too distantly
related to something we've seen before
but there's also things that i'll just
lump together and call contamination and
the human microbiome that's you sequence
different amounts of host dna
in certain samples than others there are
laboratory reagents that get into the
sequencing library there's a bunch of
other dna that gets in there that isn't
a microbe and shouldn't be considered
sort of an unknown category so you have
a mixture in your unknown unmapped bin
of things that are knowable but you just
don't know and things that shouldn't be
in a metagenomic analysis and we don't
know which are which
so that unknown category is problematic
and therefore
the
the statistic that everyone uses
relative abundance or the percent of
classified reads so i have a count of
reads to every gene i normalized by some
guess about its length and then i want
to divide by the library size and then
it should be comparable across samples
but the problem is for little microbes
swimming around here i have different
amounts of gray ones in different
samples
and for genes if i cut open these
microbes and dump out their genes then
there's some genes that are unknown or
unannotated as well a lot and gray here
is shown as about
four tenths of the microbes of the genes
it can be much higher than that
but along with that there's also the
contamination
and what happens then is if i calculate
relative abundance and i don't include
the gray category
all the rel everything relative
abundance is a compositional statistic
it's by definition the relative
abundance is sum to one
and so it
jacks up as you would expect
the relative abundance of all the
microbes
um and therefore uh people have tried to
correct for that by making a category of
all the unmapped reeds and calling that
gray thing a microbe essentially and
that might be
more than 50 percent of the reads but if
you include it you at least aren't
biasing these other estimates hopefully
that would pull away the reads that
would be
increasing the relative abundances
unnaturally here
the problem is if this gray thing also
contains host reeds or laboratory
contamination or things that aren't
microbes then you're actually pushing
down the relative abundances of
everything
and this can
induce a bias on the scale of something
looking like 20 percent versus 80
percent of the your library quite easily
so as the amount of novel things
increases the bias increases to pretty
astronomical levels and so that
we think that these numbers these
estimates that are commonly used are
just not comparable across samples at
all
they may be pretty comparable for two
genes in the same sample but a cross
sample is not comparable
there is a great solution and and it is
that there are individual genes that
every cell has i already alluded to 16s
which was targeted and sequenced for
many decades
they
we and our colleagues have identified
several hundred genes that are present
in every bacterial genome
and they're present and in exactly one
copy in every bacterial genome so
they're built in controls that shouldn't
be
biased and so what we can do is to try
to figure out what's going on at a
taxonomic level by using only these
genes so if i just want to know how much
of each bacterium i have i won't use the
whole library i will use only reads that
map to this set of taxonomically
informative genes
and that is a fixed target size
and we don't have to worry about
therefore this gray bar anymore we have
a measurement that's comparable across
samples so that's the solution for taxa
but it doesn't solve
quantifying the amount of a gene because
i'm not using most of the data most
genes aren't in this set and these
certainly aren't the biologically
interesting genes i have to go back to
the rest of the data to solve this
problem
so
as the databases get better
and more there's less and less gray in
the database
i think that a similar approach might be
useful here right now i don't think
that's possible
what we're advocating for is a different
statistic that i actually think is more
biologically meaningful which is to try
to calculate for a gene the average copy
number per cell so the
thought experiment is if i went in and i
randomly sampled a cell
how many copies of the gene would be in
there
so half would mean that about half the
cells in the community have one copy
so i pull one there's a 50 chance that
it has it or a two would be that
compared to one of these universal
single copy genes it's there's usually
two of them so if the red with the
single copy jeans blue would have a copy
number of two
and so
we'd like to try to estimate the average
genomic copy number but as i told you we
don't know which reads come from each
organism so if you're following me
you're now probably thinking how the
heck does she figure out the copy number
per cell because she has no idea which
reads come from which cell they're all
mixed together
how would you deconvolute this
so
the reason
i want a deconvoluted or another sort of
way of showing the argument i just made
is here red
is the
this red gene and blue is this blue gene
in this example here they're equal copy
number per cell
and their relative abundances are fifty
percent if nothing is unmeasured if i
measure everything
and their average genomic copy number is
one
but here in these cells red is still one
copy number blue is two so there's twice
as many and i get that here
um but uh the the red is only 25 percent
of the reeds because there's a green
gene in these organisms as well
and so the relative amount of red versus
blue depends on green being there this
other gene
the relative abundance shouldn't be
changing of the you know i want some
quantification that doesn't depend on
whether the organism also happens to
carry some additional genes or not
i want to compare a measurement that
would be comparable and that this
average genomic copy number is
comparable every cell in this example
has one copy of the red gene and you can
see that red is constant
it doesn't change when i add two green
genes or i increase the amount of the
blue genes so that's why we think this
would be a nice statistic the question
is how the heck do you estimate it how
would you estimate this from this pool
of data
the answer was actually in my problem at
the beginning of the talk which was when
i tested for differentially abundant
genes i found the ribosome and all these
other housekeeping genes going up and
down between samples when i know they
shouldn't because i know every cell has
exactly one copy of each of these
ribosomal proteins
so those are built-in controls
that are in every cell that shouldn't be
changing and when i found them changing
i knew i had a problem with
quantification and so can i fix that
problem by looking at how these built-in
controls basically are varying across
samples
and we had this idea at the same time as
some folks
at elhan borenstein's lab
uh luckily elena and i met uh when i
gave a talk and uh we were preparing our
papers in parallel and they came out
last year and they essentially do the
exact same thing so this is one of these
great examples where there was an
obvious solution and it uh encouraged us
that we had converged on it at the same
time that they did
the idea is that there are some genes
um there are a few hundred and we
actually went it down to 30
that are the best
examples of genes that are in every
single cell at exactly one copy and we
determine that from looking at genomes
so we need to continually update this
list as more genomes are sequenced we
may decide one of these 30 isn't so good
anymore we find another one that's
better
but we have a set of genes that should
be at one copy number so if in a sample
i see a lot of reads mapping then i know
that i've got higher coverage
of all the genes in that sample and if i
see a few reads in a given sample
mapping to these single copies and i
know on average i have low coverage in
that sample and i can use the reads
mapping to these built-in controls
to normalize
and it turns out what these genes are
doing is providing an estimator of the
average genome size so i said that the
relative abundance of red goes up and
down depending on how many of the green
genes i have as the genomes get bigger
then the amount of reeds would be lower
just by chance and so part of our
calculation
is to look at rij which is the amount of
reads mapping to a given one of these
universal genes
we through simulations using genomes
figure out the relationship between that
and the actual size of the genomes
which is this const this co this
constant c that we estimate by
simulation and that's there because they
aren't exactly universal or exactly
single copy and then we weight the genes
because all 30 don't perform equally
well and we get this estimator of
average genome size which is just about
you can think of it as as a indirect
measurement of the coverage that i would
have
of any genome in the sample and then i
can get a statistic an estimator for the
um
we call rpkg you can think of it as the
copy number per cell
that uses these genome equivalents
so
um
so that solved the gene quantification
problem it doesn't give us a relative
abundance statistic but it gives us a
statistic that is
numeric and comparable across samples
and not affected by the unmapped trees
as at least not as much there's a little
bias there
so i want to summarize this first part
of the talk and tell you our
recommendations essentially for this
field and we have a review coming out
describing this in more detail that i'd
be happy to share
so keep track of data there's a lot of
sequencing data as i mentioned in public
repositories unfortunately a lot of the
sources of bias have not been tracked
and when they're not then it's
impossible to correct for them in
downstream analyses so we're making an
appeal
for better tracking of data and i'm
actually headed out tonight on a flight
to an international meeting where we're
trying to get these data standards just
like any new technology
this field is having to figure out what
its sort of minimal data standards are
we
need to think about a biologically
meaningful parameter and and i would
argue that the average genomic copy
number is a better measure than relative
abundance for genes
avoid statistics based on the percent
reads which is 90 of the software out
there is doing this
and if you're going to do comparisons of
course process raw data yourself from
scratch because any of the
analysis choices made in different
studies can definitely
introduce bias and surprisingly we
recommend for minimal if any quality
control on the data that the bias
induces basically offsets the gain and
the quality of the reads
so with this advice in hand we've now
analyzed all that publicly available
data that i mentioned
from 12 different studies in eight
countries um about 2 000 meta genomes
have been sequenced by anybody up till
now
and stephen nefak a great student in my
lab has made this web server called
metaquery where any of these results can
be publicly queried by anybody with a
they're pre-computed and this really
democratizes this sort of
analysis
approach that i'm describing because
um
anybody working on a particular gene or
pathway or microbe can search and find
how abundant across people in different
parts of the world with different
diseases or healthy or other traits how
much of my gene or my pathway or my
microbe do they have and is there an
association that i might want to know
about
and
so now in the remaining few moments i
just want to show you some of the
biological the fun biological results
that we've gleaned from this massive
meta-analysis so the first one um
i think is um amazing
and that is
that
if you take a micro black bacterius
volgas which is probably in all of our
guts right now um it has 16 sequence
genomes and each row of this heat map is
a person
whose vector where we've used the reeds
to quantify the amount of every gene in
the genome so the columns or the genes
in the vulgates genome the color of this
bar is where in the world did that
person come from these are just 205
samples here that are mostly
from north america and europe and china
you can see where blue means the gene is
present there's a core part of the
genome where everybody's vulgaris has
those genes
but the vast majority of the genome
is not present in all of these healthy
individuals human microbiomes
their bacteria's vulgaris does not have
that gene as shown by white here and the
average sharing of genes in the strains
present and two of these people
is varies from about 10 to 50 percent on
this particular analysis so your
bacteroides velgados and mine could have
50 of the genes different
or more
um
and they aren't random genes a lot of
them are
very important for example in how this
microbe metabolizes your diet
no this is metagenome so i kind of
nuanced this but we've now like
taken the metagenomic library and
deconvoluted it down at to the strain
level gene presence absence for all the
prevalent microbes in the human
microbiome
right
um so
we take the 16 genomes that have been
sequenced so you need some whole genomes
and then we ask if there's support in
the meta genome for each of the genes in
the reference genome to be present what
the method doesn't do is tell you about
genes that are in the meta genome but
not in the reference genome there's
another tool called con strains that
eric allman colleagues worked on that
tries to
find strains that
and it doesn't exactly do this but you
can kind of tweak it to find the genes
that are in your metagenome but not in
the reference this is back to the
reference so this is an underestimate of
the diversity
and then on top of that even these core
genes have obviously mutations in them
so we've quantified every single
nucleotide polymorphism in each of these
people my people's metagenomes and some
of them are damaging to the proteins
and i have a postdoc nandita gerudi
recently joined who's looking for
signatures of selection in those genes
the
next thing that we did was to ask then
for which genes vary the most across
different hosts because you can see
there's huge variability and um
this should not come as any surprise to
the folks who've worked with rna-seq and
you maybe you were thinking about this
when i said that the ribosome was one of
the genes that was associated with
crohn's disease
when you sample sequencing reads
it's a poisson-like or a negative
binomial-like process where the mean
depends the variance depends on the mean
and so if i'm going to test to design a
statistical test for the most variable
gene families i need to realize that
those are going to be the most abundant
ones if i don't consider this mean
variance relationship
but that's easy to model
so
we
designed a test statistic that has a
gene specific mean
a study effect because we want to
integrate data across different studies
and even after the best normalization
there might be batch effects in the data
so that's what these are and then we
look at the residual variance that's not
explained by the model so in any
individual persons
uh subject s is
microbiome the amount of gene g the
variance not explained as epsilon and we
just take the variance of the residuals
from this linear model and that's our
test statistic
to get a null distribution we use the
negative binomial and we which considers
this mean variance relationship so we're
essentially testing for genes that are
off the line here so not that are high
variance per se but are higher variance
than you would expect given their mean
and that's what this is so these are the
study effects these are three studies
and you can see there are differences in
the mean level of genes across study
these are just batch effects or maybe
biological differences between these
different study people in these
different studies these are the
residuals after fitting the model and
we're asking is there more variance for
one gene family compared to another gene
family so this one has low variance this
one has higher variance
and
so we've moved from this picture to one
where there's the mean variance
relationship is adjusted for it also
adjusts for the phylogenetic diversity
of the gene family because things that
are widely spread also tend to be higher
variants and so what happens is
something like the ribosome was one of
our most variable gene families after
correction it's no longer
whereas like this um
biosynthesis pathway was low and it
actually increases after correcting for
the mean variance relationship so this
was a low abundant gene that we weren't
able to detect that it was actually more
variable than we realized
and then this example of type 2
secretion
it was changed a little bit by the
normalization but not a lot so it's not
a linear change on everybody the
different gene families are affected
differently depending on where they lie
on this mean variance relationship and
we think it gives a more biologically
meaningful
description of variability
we analyze all the genes
in all the publicly available data and
these are different pathways this gets
back to the functional stability
question there are pathways that are
very stable as i'm showing in blue
across different individuals
but
and these are stacked bar plots of the
genes in a given pathway but even some
of these quite stable pathways have
parts of the pathway that are variable
across hosts
and they aren't just sort of random
picks from the pathway diagram they tend
to be particular branches or up at the
top or down at the bottom of the pathway
that have biological meaning
and then there are some very variable
gene families like for example methane
metabolism
now we have a quantity we can compare
across individuals
and at this level we found associations
with phenotype that were much more
meaningful than we looked at species so
we found almost in the human microbiome
project we looked at every gene family
every pathway every species every genus
every taxonomic and functional group
that we had quantified and found almost
and there were about 300
medical record phenotypes on each
patient and we found
basically no statistically significant
associations with anything
but i think it was a resolution problem
once we drill down to strain level in
genes we are finding many associations
with host traits
so here's an example in this vulgatis
genome that i talked about before where
there's a lot of difference between your
strains and my strains
this is an operon a pathway that's
included by a set of side-by-side genes
in the vulgatis genome
that
is
absent in individuals with higher body
mass index so it's associated with
obesity and here's another pathway in
the same genome that's actually
associated with lower body mass index so
those associated with being a lean
individual
and so our metaquery server allows you
to look up any of these genes or
pathways and find the differences
i thought this was really interesting as
we looked in the publicly available data
as i alluded to earlier they're now
individuals from eight different
countries
12 different studies who've had this
shotgun experiment done on them they're
not so many from the southern hemisphere
but we found some really interesting
structure
so this is a google map and i'm showing
where the sampling locations were with
the red dots this is the phylogenetic
tree of this particular bacterium
eubacterium rectale
built from the strain level data of the
ractali in each of these people so the
leaves of the tree are hosts these are
the people whose microbiome were
sequenced the color is what continent
the host came from
what you can see is there's a lot of
structure for this particular bacterium
in the strains there's a clade here with
all the chinese individuals the strains
in china are different
and the strains in other parts of the
world the strains in the southern
hemisphere and red and purple tend to be
different and there's essentially two
main groups and some subgroups present
in europe and north america but they're
mixed like this clade right here is
shared between north america and europe
so this bug gets around but it doesn't
get everywhere because you can see that
where people live really has a
relationship with the strain that they
have
in contrast this other bacterium
vectoroides uniformis
has
a star-like phylogeny it doesn't matter
where you are in the world you could
have a strain right now in your body
that's the closest person strain in the
whole world is in china
um and it was not found however in the
individuals in north uh in peru and
tanzania so this thing gets around but
only in the industrialized countries
now
diet location
access to medical care antibiotics other
things are confounded here all those
variables so we don't know if this is
geographic structure if this is
selection based on say having taken
antibiotics if it's to do a diet or
lifestyle
and that's what we're drilling down to
try to figure out now
i'm very interested in testing a
hypothesis called the hygiene hypothesis
that talks about microbes that are
present in our were present in our
ancestors and have been lost
in individuals in north america and
europe so the opposite of the pattern
that i just showed you
and the idea is that we co-evolve with
many microbes we've eliminated most of
them and that this might at least
partially explain the rise of autoimmune
diseases in industrialized countries
we are seeing strong support so far for
this hypothesis in our analyses
these are this is a grad student that i
worked with that's in south africa
collecting data from croissant
hunter-gatherers who live a traditional
lifestyle don't have access to dental or
medical care
and the majority of the microbes that we
found in their oral microbiome
were not found
a lot of them were not found in north
americans
and then in the publicly available data
here from different countries these are
the uh percent of them is an estimate of
the percent of your microbiome that's
from a species that's unknown
and you can see even for most of us
that's around 50 but if you're one of
these individuals living a
hunter-gatherer lifestyle in peru it's
much higher
so there is
a lot of unknowns and that's not
surprising most of the sequences in the
database came from an individual from
one of these countries so there's a huge
bias in the reference data and there's a
lot of unknown in all of us but it looks
like these individuals may have lost
more of that component and that may be
related to autoimmune disease that's the
hypothesis
the last thing i want to show you is
that we're not only looking in the human
body we're thinking about the
environment the built environment the
air conditioners
the things in our homes
the soil outside that's putting
particulate matter into the air
the plants that are
have fungi growing on them that are
aerosoling into the air we breathe
and thinking about the distributions of
microbes in the natural world because
that affects our health and for
something like the bacteroides
uniformist that seems to get around
everywhere the
uh natural world might actually be the
source of our microbiome rather than
another human
and indeed we've found a lot of
antibiotic resistance genes for example
seem to come from soil
so josh ledoux who's a postdoc in my lab
has an ecology background and he does
something called niche modeling where
you essentially try to predict where
microbes what the natural distributions
of microbes are
he used it in a kind of fun project to
reconstruct what the
midwestern united states looked like in
terms of microbial taxonomic and
functional diversity prior to
agriculture so before we wiped out all
the tall grass prairie and put in corn
and soybeans what microbes were there so
this is reconstructing an extinct
ecosystem
but the health relevant application is
actually projecting to the future so
these are his maps of the united states
red means an increase in the amount of
these
pathogenic
fungal allergens
and he can predict with climate change
increases in some of these very populous
states including california in
particular fungal allergens as we move
into a hotter world and so i think this
is a really interesting application of
the method that i just showed
okay so to wrap up um
we are just scratching the surface
there's a ridiculous amount of data and
i think a lot of unsolved algorithmic
and statistical problems but i i think
we're starting to get a handle on
understanding the variety that's out
there we've revealed cryptic variation
that was completely missed a couple
years ago in analyses by being able to
drill down to the strain in the species
level
and revealed this complex ecosystem
and i think this is very exciting not
just from a basic science perspective
but the microbiome and i didn't show
this data today but the microbiome is
very malleable you might guess that from
that map with the star-like phylogeny
that some of these microbes can change
quite quickly
my strains could be different tomorrow
after i get on an airplane or eat a
different diet
that makes the research more complicated
it's a moving target unlike the human
genome which is pretty stable modulo
cancer
but it's really exciting from a
therapeutic perspective because if it's
something we can manipulate and if it
really plays a causal role in our
biology and in disease
then it could really change health care
in the future so um i i i'm exercising a
lot of caution and we've
our lab has
been a bit obnoxious in pointing out all
the problems in the field at the moment
but i actually generally feel like
there's a lot of hope and that we're
just starting to get the tools that we
can can leverage this data for for good
in the coming years
i'd like to thank the folks who did the
work in particular a great student
steven nafak
led a lot of the work that i showed
and i also showed results from
josh and patrick
uh alluded to nandita who does the
population genetics and svetlana is
working on the hygiene hypothesis and
inflammatory bowel disease so thanks
very much and i'm happy to take
questions
yeah in every genome there's about 30
000 bacterial genomes that have been
sequenced and they all have exactly one
copy
believe it or not it's sort of shocking
but there are 30 such genes
30 000 bacteria have been sequenced so
far we need to update the list once we
have a hundred thousand genomes to make
sure that that's still true
but right now they appear to be single
copy and the weights that i had
were in there empirically to sort of
adjust for the fact that in what's out
there they probably aren't perfectly
single copy and we found in simulations
that some of them are more more reliably
single copy than others so maybe it's
like 99.9 percent of the time there's
exactly one copy but sometimes there's
two
certain parts of the microbiome are
really stable so
life your lifetime so like anyone who's
taken antibiotics ever
that that that has a signature i can i
can you know do an unsupervised
clustering and find the people who've
taken antibiotics versus not essentially
for a long time you carry a signature of
whether you were born vaginally or by a
cesarean birth whether you were
breastfed or bottle-fed various things
that happen
on the other hand
if you go from eating a vegan diet and
you eat nothing but meat for 24 hours
the majority of the microbiome changes
so there's a minority component that's
very stable and tracks these sort of
major disturbances and colonization
events throughout your lifetime but a
lot of it is dynamic so
the difference between two people
um and you
your own microbiome a few years later is
about the same
the what
yeah it's really important so um
in the analyses i was showing i was
using like one data point from an
individual to do those and then sort of
checking if things hold in the other
sample but you need to
you can't sort of throw in two samples
on the same person
the methods
oh yeah so they used a little more than
30 they didn't winnow it down as much
and then they use machine learning to
kind of weight them a bit in a bit
fancier way and so we they the methods
are identical essentially and actually
we're using their tool a little bit
sometimes in my lab because there's
certain things about it works better so
you know that yeah it's there they're
very equivalent but they took sort of
different approaches we curated more and
modeled less and they kind of did more
machine learning they did more of a
black box they also tried to account for
gc content of the genes because they're
sort of you know based on gc content you
get more or less
reads i'm not sure that made a big
difference
when you sort of turn off that feature
it doesn't change the performance too
much but they put that in there
yeah so i didn't i didn't give a
definitive answer did i
i think it's mostly batch effects
yeah so um we've tried to go back and
analyze it uh counting using the methods
i described most of those studies didn't
share their raw data they had already
processed it enough that we were unable
to totally remove the batch effects so i
didn't come back and show you like
here's the answer because actually
that's a problem
yeah yeah but i believe it's like there
may be some biological differences but i
think it's mostly batch
yes
yeah
great question so um
how useful will the long raids be
um
so um
long reads are really helpful if you
want to do assembly so everything i
describe is essentially assembly free i
think there's a lot of value in doing
assembly i think it's been incredibly
error prone up until now the long reads
will help
but what i
didn't emphasize but i'll go back to is
our gene catalog so we have a catalog of
10 million genes that we're using
and these include um this igc integrated
gene catalog that pure borg's group put
together by doing gene level assemblies
including some longer reads this of of
specifically human microbiome samples so
not like bacteria from the ocean and all
these things this is like what genes did
we find in the human microbiome this
gene catalog is incredibly useful so i
think the big application for the long
reads is to improve the reference
databases and then you can short read
sequence the samples for a large part um
but um
in less complicated communities with
only like
20 different types of bacteria or
something then you may you know it might
be a good idea to you know assemble
whole genomes because of course there's
interesting questions you can ask once
you have the whole genome assembled
about
whether genes are you know evolving
together or things like this so
um
what would i do so we're sequencing some
non-human primates right now and we're
doing mostly shotgun but we're doing a
little bit of long reads to try to get
the gene catalog because i showed you
that people from tanzania and peru
hardly any of their genes were in the
database well it's worse for chimpanzees
or baboons there's almost nothing in the
database so we're doing some long reads
to make a gene catalog
i think a mix the answer is that both
both will be useful if you had a fixed
amount of money i think it depends on
your scientific goals but i i feel
strongly the
long reads help assembly and assembly is
helpful for the gene
catalog yeah
so um
it depends a lot on this database so uh
we also study the microbes in the ocean
and the data the the
it's just less well-known what's there
the database is sparser and so there um
like
10 or something might map to anything in
a database in the human microbiome with
this good gene catalog we're getting
like 70 80 mapping now whereas it was
like 20 or 40 a couple years ago so
that's part of why i'm advocating for
these gene catalogs it makes a really
big difference to have a good good
database
thank you guys
hey
yeah
you